Suddenly, if something happened to me, it happened to us. I
couldn't find anything. The stones were in my water. I couldn't breathe or
speak. The girl was yelling at me, and
I was falling into [music] Ida. I put my hands in something and looked for my mother's turnips. All the rent was gone from me, and it was all from me. I would say, oh mother, this is easy, oh mother.  Hey, I'm
alive, we
don't find people voting and saying, "Follow us, follow us,"
and we say, "Follow us, follow us." From here, from the text, we throw it and the stones. We don't know where to go. We don't know where the truth is. Follow us, follow us, follow us. Stay safe. Get out the clothes you bought. Her
name is Malika.
She sleeps next to me and my mother. Here I give her
these forbidden things.  And I push, I put it down and I was ready to
put it. Where do I want to put it? The house has become a ruin. There is nothing left,
nothing
left. They stopped for you. God suffices me, and He is the best of the best.
All the countries are
watching. Yes, our homes have come too. Where is the
soul, where is the pearl, where is the
limit? God suffices me, and He is the best disposer of affairs for every one.
We are released by the countries.  Israel, may God bless
them. We attended the resistors until the last moment, until the last breath. We
would leave our homes, even if they killed me.